Here is my solution.
You can see it looks pretty similar to the way we solved the zebra puzzle.
We did the same technique of assigning something to each of these numbers--
bottom to 1, top to 5. These we left unassigned.
Then we have this for loop.
I chose not to use a generator expression here,
because I thought this looked pretty readable in a simple for loop.
We have this extended if statement, where each of these clauses corresponds
to one of the original constraints of the problem.
For example, we know that Hopper doesn't live on the top floor.
Key is not on the bottom. Liskov isn't on the top or the bottom.
Perlis lives on a higher floor than Kay.
Richie and Liskov do not live on adjacent floors,
so the absolute value of their difference must be greater than one.
Likewise with Liskov and Kay.
When we return this and run the function,
we get our solution--3, 2, 4, 5, 1.
This means that Hopper lives on the 3rd floor, Kay on the 2nd,
Liskov on the 4th, Perlis 5th, Richie 1st.